this is damn by the way dad is like a
creative genius partner in crimes today
today all the hellos I'm engaged now
do I feel older different strange I feel
pretty good never felt better
never never felt younger super amped
after making videos yes this video is
sponsored by skill shape before you
start commenting are why making an ad
sponsored video you heard to my eyes
erasing my time
let me tell you something about
sponsored videos the brown doesn't have
anything to say over the actual content
if anything you should be stoked because
for me as a creator I'm getting paid in
order to make these films and in order
to make more funds and what I'm doing
with these sponsored videos is saving up
money season 2 which is 20 episodes and
20 different concepts
20 new ideas and 20 completely newsrooms
which is in my mind gonna be really
awesome
therefore I still really hope you enjoy
this video and other than that we'll
talk about skill share later so what
happened with Casey nice
let's call this once upon a shocking
Saturday morning Casey and myself went
hiking up lines hidden cave top we
started talking about the industry and
how I was unhappy directing TV
commercials and wanted to get his advice
on moving over to YouTube time flew by
and the next minute we were in the ocean
surfing and Sharky waters when Katie
said you know Dan you said you should
seriously consider coming to New York
City I think he could do great things
here he then told me about this place he
was starting called v6a it's an
opportunity ropes of being a creator on
YouTube two months later I found myself
boosted boarding through downtown
Manhattan with a bag full of camera gear
and a camera in each hand keeping up
with arguably the most driven creator on
the platform but then what happened what
am i doing back in South Africa was I
using Casey for clout did I just not
enjoy New York or was I lazy and
mooching off Casey oh did I die
none of that [ __ ] this actually yo
what's going on I came back to South
Africa to propose to my now fiancé Gabi
which I will link that video below well
Casey and Candice we're giving birth to
Georgie nice start so it just seemed
like the perfect time to come back and
make all of this happen I'm still very
much a part of the 360 movement and will
be returning to New York with gaps very
soon being away from New York City for a
couple of weeks really makes you miss
the fast pace the random screams and the
most interesting humans on the planet
but also my good mates my mentor I must
shed up homie Casey nice start I knew
that being around him daily and watching
him play his thing from the inside would
be a great opportunity to learn
therefore I kept this blue book with me
at all times by 2018
idea book where I wrote down most of my
ideas that eventually turned into
YouTube phones but most importantly the
spinach Casey's mind how he works
important note Casey has an auteur of
the following steps and these outlooks
are purely my analysis of spending time
and learning from him here are the five
most important lessons to an all-rounded
successful life as a YouTube creator I
learned from Casey Neistat
one family first
here's an amazing father and husband he
works extremely hard but has a balance
he always makes time to hang out with
Candace his son when he's in town
daughter and our new daughter when we
shooting together and it's getting near
6 p.m. and the evening you'll always be
like hurry up dad I need to get back to
my family therefore you know it's
amazing to see someone who's so
passionate about his work who will then
drop his work and ran home to spend time
with the most important people too but
but family doesn't have to be your blood
it can also be your homies find your
tribe and love them hard - only a full
series tired
a wise man escapes this villager Casey
and I have today the most random places
this is because when Casey does is
maximize the time of alertness he has
every single day most people ask how
does Casey get so much done in a day and
that's pretty because of the fact that
he's awake for a lot longer than most
people
let me explain like this if you wake up
at 5 a.m. every day instead of 8 a.m.
there for you saving 3 hours times up at
365 days divided by 24 and you end up
with 45 extra days each year and this is
the kind of mentality that Casey has 3
only 1 take ever for me as a film
director and perfectionist this one
completely freaks me out before Casey it
helps him act on impulse and utilizes
intuition in order to tell a story
this way he star main - Sammis oh this
waste our main - Sammy is able to be so
bloody consistent he has essentially
perfected the art of imperfection for
never rolled on somebody else's expense
and this one's pretty self-explanatory
it's ultimately always have respect and
don't be a dick and as we say in South
Africa just be liquor 5 free is the most
expensive basically you don't get swayed
by people giving you free things this
isn't to take away from the genuine
people in the world that are actually
just giving you something for the sake
of giving it but unfortunately in this
new world a lot of the people that give
especially when they give something big
expect something in return in saying
that it's waving it's a focus on your
journey and rather pay for something
rather than receive it in return and
then be stuck having to do a whole bunch
of promotions which in turn would
actually end up making you money instead
of you having to spend your time doing
that for free because you got given
something therefore you got to ask
yourself therefore you've gotta ask
yourself yourself is the juice worth the
squeeze
[Music]
hmm and then if you don't have occasion
a stud there's always Skillshare which I
use to learning tips and tricks of the
trade from other Creators minds is
priceless the film industry and YouTube
creation is constantly changing and
evolving and it's very important
therefore to stay ahead of the game so
what is Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 17,000 creative business
technology and lifestyle classes and
then if you have the Premium Membership
it gives you unlimited access to
high-quality classes from experts
working in their fields so that you can
improve your skills unlock new
opportunities and do the work you
alternately love Skillshare it's also a
lot more affordable than most other
learning platforms out there with an
annual subscription at less than $10 a
mac recently I watched a lecture by
Kevin Cisco which was called
productivity today which is about
managing attention in the digital age
something that I really struggle with I
have an epic offer the first 500 people
that sign up with my unique URL get two
months of Skillshare premium for free
and then it's as low as 10 dollars a
month after that if you decide to
continue using the skill share platform
I'm gonna say that again the first 500
people that click on the link below get
two months of Skillshare premium for
free and largely don't forget you're
awesome and I'll see you next week
[Music]